hey everybody welcome back to css3 in 30
days today is day 11 and all about
internet explorer unfortunately so now
before we go forward
internet explorer has taken a lot of
Liberty to try and improve their
software and they're on like version 15
or something crazy right now I don't
really pay attention because I don't
really care but hopefully you're
watching this at some point in the
future where none of this is an issue
anymore however there are some people
who still use Internet Explorer 9 and
below which is crazy talk but luckily in
css3 and CSS we can we can kind of make
some accommodations and in my case I
just like to remove the styles for those
browsers altogether so I'm gonna show
you how to do that with something called
conditional comments jump over here and
check this out you can see here I'm
going to show you what a conditional
comment looks like and what it does so
basic conditional comment looks like
this if ie and it's wrapped in basically
an HTML comment and then you can put any
HTML in between including links to CSS
like a different ie stylesheet and then
you close it off like so you could
select different types of browsers
Internet Explorer versions rather six
seven eight nine by using the following
conditional comments you can use a
specific conditional comment for say a
version of Internet Explorer or lower so
if LTE stands for less than or equal to
ie six seven eight or nine
that styles Internet Explorer 6 or less
seven or less 8 or less nine or less or
rather those browsers register those
comments and then we have the opposite
of that which is greater than or equal
to so you could solve greater than or
equal to a six seven eight or nine or I
just like to use the the catch-all F ie
so that's Internet Explorer 6 through 9
and that will be recognized and rendered
by those specific browsers so jump over
here in our code editor and all we have
in DES 11 you can go ahead and download
that is in an index file and an IE dot
CSS file gonna run through them show you
what's going on and then we could be on
our merry way and not think about IE
anymore so right here you can see in the
head of our HTML i have a conditional
comment that's selecting IE six through
nine
and I'm just adding an IE stylesheet so
only Internet Explorer 6 through 9 will
recognize and render that comment and
then we'll tie into our CSS file which
looks like this basically I'm just I did
an asterisk selector which is catch-all
everything I'm removing the background
color and line height resetting that
really aggressively removing the course
files button and the level 2 heading tab
that sits on the side of the container
in the webpage that we have here and
then I found a complete CSS reset at
this link that's just an aggressive
reset it just resets everything to just
basic black and white text and that's
all I want for ie6 through 9 because I
don't want to have to accommodate those
browsers so I just show them my markup
which if it's semantic they should be
able to read it and get the meaning of
the website anyway so let me just go
back to our browser or index.html file
here and I want to show you one last
thing I've done right under the
conditional comments I've put
conditional comments through from 6
through 9 and basically just some text
so if your this is a test method so if
you're viewing it from a 6 7 8 or 9
you'll see the proper the respective
comment for the browser that you are
using so why don't we test that I've
taken the liberty of uploading this to
my website on my domain and there's a
web page web site called net renderer
comm where you can basically get a
screen grab of an IE browser of a live
web page so if you go to net renderer
and type in Brad Hussey dossier slash
dev slash you
aaww and I'm choose Internet Explorer 9
because for some reason 7 & 8 don't work
on my website but 9 does and if I hit
render basically what's going to happen
is it's going to take a few seconds and
then it's going to give me a rendering
screenshot of what Internet Explorer 9
how it sees my website so here you go
it's a basic black and white it's got
the text you can read it and then if you
notice here you're viewing with Internet
Explorer 9 you can't see that in my
Chrome browser because obviously it's
not IE but here it is you're viewing at
Internet Explorer 9 and the styles are
completely
so that all they can do is read it
perfect that's all I really need so I
know that was kind of a quick lesson but
feel free if you really care to utilize
this strategy on your own blogs and
websites if you just want to remove the
styles altogether you could do simply
what I did or if you want to take a
little bit more of an accommodating
approach you can do that as well
play around there are a number of
different browsing tests browser testing
tools such as browser stack but that's
paid
whereas net render is just a screen grab
of what IE sees your website how it sees
your website so really that's kind of
all I didn't want to spend a lot of time
on this because it's quite simple
conditional comment an IE CSS file and
just remove the Styles pretty
straightforward I hope you're having a
great day and tomorrow I'll see you in
day 12 which is gonna be fun we're gonna
be playing around with some css3
variables
[Music]